today is about standard deviation after
this video you will know what standard
deviation is how you can calculate it
and why there are two different formulas
and finally what is the difference to
the variance
at the end of this video i have a tip
for you so let's get started
so what is the standard deviation the
standard deviation is a measure of how
much your data scatters around the mean
so the standard deviation has something
to do with the scatter of your data for
example how different the answers of
your respondents are
here's an example
let's say you measure the height of a
small group of people
the standard deviation tells us how much
your data scatters around the mean
so we first need to calculate the mean
you can get a mean simply by summing the
heights of all individuals and dividing
it by the number of individuals
let's say we get a mean value of
155 centimeters
now we want to know how much each person
deviates from the mean
so we look at the first person who
deviates 18 centimeters from the mean
value the second person deviates 8
centimeters from the mean value
and so on
finally person number six deviates six
centimeters from the mean value
so simply said people that are very
small or very tall deviate more from the
mean value
now of course you're not interested in
the deviation of each individual person
from the mean value
but you want to know how much the
persons deviate from the mean value on
average
so how much do these persons on average
deviate from the mean value this is what
the standard deviation tells us
in our example the average deviation
from the mean value is
12.06 centimeters and now of course the
next question is how can we calculate
the standard deviation you can calculate
the standard deviation with the
following formula
sigma is the standard deviation
n is the number of persons
x i is the size of one single person and
x dash is the mean value of all people
so the standard deviation is the root of
the sum of square deviations divided by
the number of values
for our example this means that we
calculate the size of the first person
minus the mean and square that then the
size of the second person minus the mean
and then square that and so on until we
arrive at the last person
then we divide this number by the number
of people so 6 and take the root of it
the result is then
12.06 centimeters
so each individual person has some
deviation from the mean
but on average the people deviate 12.06
centimeters from the mean
which is now our standard deviation
now you might notice one thing i always
talk about the average deviation from
the mean
but for the average deviation i would
actually just add up all deviations and
divide it by the number of participants
just like you calculate a mean value
right
you're absolutely right but there are
different mean values
in the case of the standard deviation
it's not the arithmetic mean which is
used
but the quadratic mean
if the arithmetic mean would be used the
result would be zero every time
so far so good but now there's one more
thing to consider
there are two slightly different
formulas for the standard deviation in
the first formula there is a deviation
by n and in the other one there is a
deviation by n minus one
but why that why are there two different
formulas
usually you want to know the standard
deviation of the whole population for
example you want to know the standard
deviation of hate of all american
professional soccer players
now if you had the hate of all american
soccer players
you would take this equation with one
divided by n
however it is usually not possible to
investigate the entire population
so you take a sample
then you use this sample to estimate the
standard deviation of the population
in that case you use this formula
therefore whenever you have data of the
whole population and you want to
calculate the standard deviation for
just this data you use 1 divided by n
therefore
whenever you have data of the whole
population and you want to calculate the
standard deviation for just this data
you use 1 divided by n
if you only have one sample and you want
to estimate the standard deviation you
use n minus 1.
so to keep it simple if your survey
doesn't cover the whole population you
always use the formula on the right side
likewise if you have conducted a
clinical study for example
then you also use the formula on the
right side to infer the population
let's look at the next question now
what is the difference between the
standard deviation and the variance
as you now know the standard deviation
is the average distance from the mean
the variance now is the squared average
distance from the mean
so we have one and the same formula the
only difference is that in order to
calculate the standard deviation we take
the root
in order to calculate the variance we
don't do that to put it the other way
around the variance is the squared
standard deviation and the standard
deviation is the root of the variance
however this squaring results in a
figure which is quite difficult to
interpret
since the unit of the calculated
variance does not correspond to the
original data
for this reason it is advisable to
always use the standard deviation to
describe a sample as this makes
interpretation a lot easier for you
the standard deviation is always in the
same unit as the original data
in our example this would be centimeters
and finally as promised i have a tip for
you
if you want to calculate the standard
deviation you can easily do it online
with beta tab
just visit datadept.net
copy your data into the table
select the variable you want to
calculate
and afterwards you will get the standard
deviation in a very easy way
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time bye bye
you